hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2014 crime and comedy movie called from
vegas to macau
the movie begins with a mafia boss
entering a restaurant full of his
subordinates one of them stutters to
talk and seems to behave like an idiot
but the boss likes him because he is
loyal
he angrily faces a couple who seem
unable to pay their debt when he wants
to end their negotiation and gets ready
to leave the restaurant he asks his
stuttering subordinate where his car is
suddenly a taxi crashes through the
restaurant's front door and causes chaos
the mafia boss and his men quickly
escape through the back door only to
find they are all tricked by the
stuttering guy
turns out he is a con man called cool
along with benz the taxi driver who is
also his dad and carl his cousin as the
person posing as the husband in debt
working to bring down mafias and
gangsters
they tie the mafia boss and report him
to the police
although risky they need to work that
way to get enough money to fund benz's
wife's heart transplantation cool's
stepbrother lionel who works as a police
officer also takes care of his mother
cool notices lionel's injured eye to
which he replies that he just had a
laser operation and nothing to worry
about
coming home ben suddenly receives an
invitation from his old best friend ken
who is labeled the magic hand as he
never loses any card games and is
rumored to be able to correctly guess
upside down poker cards
ken is coming to macau and wants to
throw his birthday party there so benz
and his family are invited they go to
macau and run into a beautiful girl at
the airport carl aggressively flirts
with her but she is annoyed so she
quickly gets into her car and leaves
arriving at ken's party they are warmly
welcomed by kan and his subordinates
turns out the girl from the airport is
rainbow his daughter ken is challenged
to a poker game with mah shung fat a
businessman and he asks carl to play
along with him
meanwhile rainbow flirts with cool
saying she wants a teddy bear doll in
one of his father's door prizes
back in hong kong an organization called
doa is holding a top secret meeting
hosted by its boss mr gao
the company turns out to organize big
money laundering schemes through
football betting even regulating the
results of the game by tricking the
football players so a big amount of
money can be transferred from one party
to another without raising police
suspicion
lionel is disguised as a security
officer able to see and hear everything
happening in the meeting room meanwhile
another police officer luo who disguises
herself as gao's loyal assistant has not
been granted access to the meeting and
only observes from her secret
surveillance trailer with ha another
hong kong police officer turns out
lionel's i was implanted with a
surveillance contact lens so he can
record everything happening in the
meeting
after a while gao's men led by guiyan
are informed that lionel is a spy so
they disrupt the meeting to catch lionel
fortunately he escapes by jumping with
his parachute
meanwhile at ken's party in macau the
time for the door prize arrives ken
deliberately gives cool the big teddy
bear that rainbow wants as a signal for
cool to approach her sometime later cool
only reacts coldly as carl and ben's get
more expensive prizes then they head
home
carl is still disappointed with rainbow
refusing him so cool suggests they eat
something outside to enlighten the mood
unbeknownst to them lionel comes to the
house while walking home from eating
cool and carl encounter gui yan and
other gal's men cool prevents a fight
from happening by excusing carl and
explaining that he is drunk although yen
counter-attacks carl and hits loose one
of his teeth meanwhile not far from them
lionel is caught and killed the next
morning ken is eating at a local diner
when some policeman led by ha want to
talk to him at a rooftop ken also meets
with luo
ha explains that the police are planning
to catch gao who is already in hong kong
their biggest chance to catch him lionel
has been found dead but without the
advanced contact lens embedded in his
eyes which contains important proof of
gao's crime
they want him to challenge gao in
tomorrow night's charity event and win
so gal will become furious but weak for
the police to catch him
ken needs to think through the offer
first
he leaves by making shooting noises with
his mouth leading the police to believe
snipers are shooting at them
cool and carl go to ken's house aiming
to give rainbow her much-wanted teddy
bear however she does not like that carl
is the one who gives it to her and does
not let them in
ken arrives home to find the two
standing in front of his doorstep so he
invites them in
cool expresses his intentions to learn
from him but ken only accepts him as his
protege if he completes his challenges
after failing him several times he
instructs cool to stay at home and build
a card pyramid while he rainbow and carl
go swimming at the club
there they encounter gao who
enthusiastically invites ken to a game
in tomorrow's charity event
when they arrive home cool is almost
finished building his card pyramid but
carl sneezes and blows off the whole
structure
cool is pissed but ken tells him to do
another favor to watch his house for
several days when he is away
he introduces them to his house's
advanced security system that provides
booby traps and countermeasures against
intruders
meanwhile gao's men catch bands at his
home and interrogate him about the
contact lens location but benz cannot
give them anything he is given a toxic
serum that weakens him then the men
leave at the charity event ken figures
out that he will accept gal's challenge
they play poker which is highly
anticipated by the audience
gow is such a good player that he can
catch up with ken's skills and the game
always ends up in a draw
meanwhile gal's men intrude on ken's
house cool and rainbow can hide and
activate the security system they notice
that the teddy bears eye contains a
special device which is actually
lionel's surveillance contact lens
through his secretary ken is informed
that his house is intruded so he wants
to quickly finish his game with gow and
heads home
however gao challenges him to one more
match
ken wins impressively and abruptly
leaves a group of police officers
including luo also arrive at his house
and help fend off the intruders
luo is shot on the upper arm but manages
to survive
rainbow is hurt seems to not remember
anything including cool
cool and carl head home to find an
absent-minded band salvaging food from
garbage bins a side effect of the toxic
serum given by gau's men
the next day luo in her cover is gao's
assistant is arranging his inquiries
while gao deliberately talks to her and
touches her upper arm
she feels blood dripping from her wound
but still manages to cover it up
gao asks her to have dinner with him
where he drugs her drink and causes her
to become dizzy and absent-minded
she also seems to laugh maniacally and
is more honest to answer questions
fortunately ken arrives to escort her
away from gao even manages to splash the
drug onto gao's assistant's face causing
him to admit the truth that gao already
knows that luo is a disguised police
officer and he deliberately pressed her
wounds earlier
ken drives luo to a particular point
where other police officers are waiting
to give her further treatments
after driving her carl calls him to
inform benz's condition at the hospital
so he heads there to check on ben's
after that ken is informed by kit his
right-hand man that a wealthy brazilian
businessman named sergio will come to
gao's investor meeting tomorrow
ken plans to find someone to take
sergio's place and asks cool to help him
they attack the real sergio and his men
but kit reveals himself to betray khan
as gow already paid him
ken and cool are caught then ken is
brought to gao's private yacht where gow
and other investors are watching a
football match
gao reveals that he also catches rainbow
and puts her in a gas chamber if ken
wants rainbow to survive he must
correctly guess the upside-down cards
presented to him or a poisonous gas will
be released at rainbow cell
other people bet that ken cannot
successfully perform the task including
kit
however gao dismisses kit and other
bodyguards out of the room leaving only
him ken and the investors gow is
confident that the police cannot catch
him as the yacht is heading to open
waters and leaving chinese territory
however one of sergio's men changes the
yacht's course back to chinese waters
the football match also catches gow and
others in surprise as barcelona the team
they are betting against suddenly wins
against real madrid at the same time ken
correctly guesses the cards and the
lights go out ken imitates gunshot
sounds causing people to frantically run
and take cover
turns out cool is the one disguising
himself as one of sergio's men and saves
rainbow from the gas chamber
she admits that she is not amnesia only
pretends to be so the contact lens
location is safe
she already sent the contact lens to the
chinese police and they are on their way
to the yacht they then encounter gui yan
who cool battles and defeats
meanwhile ken attacks gao who is
desperately trying to escape with his
pack of cards the police arrive and
subdue gao thanking ken for helping them
some time later during chinese new year
ken is about to accept cool and carl as
his proteges when cool suddenly receives
a call from someone claiming cool is
more suitable to be his protege
ken is puzzled by the fact and seems
challenged by the statement
the mysterious man on the call turns out
to be already at ken's doorstep
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching